doubler mon sacre lario c'est génial
c'est super bon de clochards la tête de
ma mère espèce de fils de gens là des
deux mamans et tu vas être homogène avis
je vais tout moggi
com mais bercy
s'est dit favorable à publier les photos
des délinquants alors hier valérie
bénaïm vous savez dit non vous étiez
contre ce café oui la night mais la nike
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à
valérie benaouda ou
madame b excusez moi avec tout le
respect que je vous dois je ne suis pas
du tout d'accord à vos propos donc
j'assume totalement ce que j'ai fait
pour moi c'est un acte de défense tout
d'abord pourquoi parce que déjà je me
fais voler dans un magasin on rentre on
prends mon sac on se barre je cours
après j'arrive pas est court plus vite
que moi alors que j'ai encore une la
moitié de mes extensions sur la tête
j'ai vu oui l'autre moitié lotois qui
n'était pas facile et que vous avez
vraiment que les faits
c'est pas une super publicité bon alors
oui attention c'est ma mère capillaire
non c'est vrai oui vous avez fait de
vous et des extensions la wii à sam
toutes les meufs un des extensions
maintenance ainsi que c'est magique
c'est vrai c'est merveilleux c'est vrai
c'est un mot qu'on m'aime moi j'en ai
même
si inquiète d extension et qui est temps
qu'il y ait la paix le mois d'août à
octobre
alors mais la night alors dites nous ce
que vous avez été un petit peu froid
c'est parce qu'arriver dailly bennahmias
complètement bientôt parce que vous
juste à faire un rappel à la loi alors
moi je vois pas la loi c'est illégal
aussi de voler nos comptes et comment
donc je suis la qualité alors qui va
gagner mais ce que je vous propose en
fait c'est simplement je comprends votre
peine je comprends votre chagrin vous
avez travaillez vous vous avez pu vous
payer ce très joli sac et a demandé en
ont un sens et un ans d'attentes oui
c'est pas une grève dure à
ma
famille aux côtés sinon c'est
bizarrement il ya aussi d'y associer des
choses personnelles
il ya des bijoux vous venez faire un nul
est juste avant bien d'identité vous
vous rendez compte c'est bien
gentil a que vous dites mais il yad
abord il ya plein de gens à qui il
arrive des choses infiniment plus grave
et si chacun commence à faire la loi et
être au dessus des lois en disant on m'a
fait quelque chose de pas bien donc moi
je suis au dessus des lois et jeux et
jeux et à mon tour jean frein la loi
pour dénoncer quelqu'un qui a enfreint
la loi on s'en sort plus ça devient ce
que disait daniel le far west et moi je
suis le far west oui et moi pardon nier
mais on importe mon chagrin ou ma
douleur etc je pense que malgré tout moi
et en tant qu'individu la loi est au
dessus de moi en revanche on a le droit
de vouloir changer la loi auquel cas je
vous je vous encourage à aller voir
votre député je ne peux rien dire à
votre député avec musique j'aime bien
j'ai bel joost beaumont député j'ai moi
j'ai pas envie que ça change la loi mais
si vous voulez changer la loi vous allez
voir votre député vous dites monsieur le
député voilà je trouve que ma que cette
loi ne me convient pas j'ai par exemple
fait une pétition je vous l'amènerai ce
que vous pourriez faire une proposition
de loi que vous allez défendre à
l'assemblée nationale selon le voilà non
mais
gilles verdez lui plaît cependant je ne
fais pas la loi moi même je fais un acte
de décence et surtout je fais une
enquête par moi même je ne condamne
jamais personne je ne suis pas juge je
suis michael c'est pas mal
moi vous êtes enquêtrice malawi et à
votre docteur oui oui et oui pas des
gens je publie vous savez qualifier
quelqu'un c'est trois ans de prison
dont vous êtes victimes mais si la
personne se fait frapper reconnaître si
lui et c'était bonheur de me suis
longuement
non mais affiché quelqu'un comme ça
c'est monstrueux c'est monstrueux pour
toi mais parce que ça retourne la
politique c'est à dire que c'est vous
qui êtes dans l'illégalité de monsec
instagram à retirer chez vous avez
publié la drogue c'est toujours dessus
l'annoncé de ce cas illégal madame c'est
illégal c'est illégal aussi de voler en
sol humide
et comme isae les policiers ont trop de
travail pour s'occuper d'un petit pays
comme le mien
excusez moi
gilles tu dis n'importe quoi on marche
sur la tête moi je soutiens à 100% mais
la night la victime ccl et c'est pas ce
jeune homme qui a volé pour rien sur
1000 euros d'affaires déjà première
chose et ensuite deuxième chose c'est
aussi une manière de faire de la
prévention elle est suivie par 1 million
de personnes c'est aussi le fait de
montrer que ça que voilà comme ça oui ça
peut se passer comme ça et que ce jeune
homme est un voleur donc c'est très bien
quelles sont les vraies stars in alors
chiche a history en dix ans on m'a volé
avoir à s'en donner s'ordonner la faute
d'accord on s'en fiche il avait qu'à pas
volé pendant photo montrée cette photo
c'est une rupture du contrat social même
les gens ne voyez là vont élever la
volée c'est pas une rupture nord mais la
légende même les gens qui défendent un
voleur ces gens mais en revanche je
comprends tout à fait je comprends votre
chagrin je comprends votre désarroi je
comprends tout ce que vous voulez
messieurs que vous donnez aujourd'hui
dans mon nom je défends détriment non
j'étais accusé moi c'est moi la victime
qui me suis fait voler la prochaine à
quel moment mademoiselle je vous ai
attaqué ou soit retirée vous disais oui
c'est illégal tu aurais pas dû jeter par
terre devant
c'est juste qu'on dirait que
je suis au tribunal
on a qu à terme échu d'accord sur le
banc des accusés bas pour l'uop à datta
khel une charité imaginez simplement
on reconnaît ce jeune homme et les gens
veulent se faire justice et le tabasse
pire encore ce jeune homme n'était pas
la bonne personne et valérie la justice
me tiendrait pour responsables donc moi
en vous disant ça à la limite presque je
pêche de sept de ses joueurs possibles
dérives bénin castaldi de réformer pour
castagner je défends pas le vol arrive
mais bon qui abolit c'est lui laplaud
c'est après se fait attraper ce qui
d'après elle s'est montrée du doigt
et à la raison il ya combien de vols par
jour de sacs à main et alors
jamais abouti
c'est un exemple à le menacer de nougat
sera utile pour les autres un avantage
pour les trois chemins bgc le corps et
je vais te raconter quelque chose qui
m'était arrivé sortie de la plaine saint
denis où je tournais une émission
j'étais dans ma voiture il ya quatre ya
deux types motos qui sont arrivées de
chaque côté de la voiture avec des
barres de pompiers ils m'ont péter les
quatre vitres de la voiture j'ai été
heureusement seul dans la voiture je
n'avais pas mon enfant à l'époque ce que
j'étais mon fils était petit ça fait une
déflagration on a présenté un attentat
j'ai hurlé j'avais du vert partout sur
moi j'ai été coupé etc j'avais moi des
vidéos également de surveillance que
j'aurais pu demander et que j'aurais pu
diffuser je ne les ai pas fait je suis
allée au commissariat de police à côté
j'étais en larmes parce que j'ai eu très
très peur et j'ai demandé à la police de
faire son travail moi je trouve que
c'est un exemple pour les autres
justement de dire voilà il ya beaucoup
de gens qui dit elle alors valérie ya
beaucoup d'autres disent vous dites
n'importe quoi sur les réseaux jolis
noms mais jorge portal
pourquoi qik est d'accord avec les
relooker d'accord ecall eric daniels non
ma chérie je suis d'accord avec mais la
neige et moi je trouve que c'est rendre
service à la société et les moyens
évolué et évoluent la société évolue il
faut que les lois évoluent je suis
d'accord avec toi on peut essayer de les
faire changer mais avec des actions
comme ça peut-être que ça va faire
évoluer la loire ferai ce que je suis
désolé mais moi si c'est mon voisin si
c'est quelqu'un que je crois je vais
méfier si je le voie ferrée service
aussi à la société parce que la police
ne veut pas malheureusement tout faire
et on n'est pas là du tout pourquoi je
lis champollion se substitue pas à la
police
qu'on va être obligé excuse moi les
rodéos en ce moment reviennent ça fait
des années qu'on parle trop et avec
l'accord si on peut si on peut voir si
l'on y font des rodéos si on peut je
suis désolé le sait on est dans le
far-west alors quand tu veux vivre oui
mais il faut pas que ça devienne de far
west on y est on y est en plein dedans
il ya qu à regarder des informations
tous les jours on y est donc on est en
danger tout le temps donc il faut se
souvient justice c'est bon voilà une
phrase il finit film c'est à dire mais
alors quand je n'étais absolument pas ce
grâce à cette vidéo et bain et j'ai eu
des chemins j'ai eu contact avec trois
magasins trois magasins qui ont la même
description et la même vidéo
surveillance avec sa
voix la voix la voix là à dire qu'il a
fait oui plusieurs fois et dans la même
semaine et dans le même quartier du coup
et ce qu'ils aient retrouvé alors ce
gars là n'ont toujours pas non mais bon
en tout cas ils sont sur la piste oui
mais sur la piste et c'est votre vrai
nom mais elle dans l'ariège mais non
c'est la cousine de david et
mercy mais la night d'avoir été avec
nous et merci
[Musique]
[Rires]